just looking at where blue origin is
looking at where spacex is today
and maybe looking out 10 20 years out
from now
are you impressed of what's happening we
just saw william shatner go up to space
yeah i was i was just watching his video
the this morning before i came here yeah
are you impressed of where things stand
today yeah i mean
i mean spacex
in particular is has
done things that are just unbelievable
um
and um
yeah i don't think anyone was
anticipating
um 20 years ago let's say when this all
started just the uh the speed with which
they'd be able to um rack up these
incredible
achievements
if you've kind of uh
even seen a little bit of how the
sausage is made and and so the the
difficulty of of doing any kind of space
travel
what they've achieved is
is just
is unbelievable
you